[Music]
welcome everybody to the first session
after the keynote of day one of cloud
next 18 we're very excited to have you
all here we appreciate a lot of you have
traveled pretty far made a lot of effort
to get here and we hope that we're able
to bring you a lot of value improve your
day-to-day developer lives before we get
started I think people are still
trickling in so one of the things that
you're going to see new this year at
next is we're trying out a little
something different for the Q&A session
so some of the larger sessions like this
one are going to use actually the same
internal QA system that we use at Google
for all of our large get-togethers it's
called dory and if you have the mobile
app or website and you go to this
session you'll see a link called the
Dory QA if you click that you're
actually to be able to submit questions
throughout the talk and vote on other
people's questions so that when we get
to the Q&A session at the end we make
sure that we answer the questions that
kind of over the most interest to people
and we'll have mics as well for people
that want to ask questions that way but
we encourage you to kind of check that
out and sort of experiment or dog food
as we like to say with us so we're here
today to talk about CI CD in a
serverless world CI CD continuous
integration and continuous delivery
server list is gonna be one of the
themes that you've heard about already
this morning you're gonna hear about
over the course of the three days and
serverless is um you know I think it's
it's it's really exciting it's
definitely one of the newer areas of
cloud and computing and developer tools
around server lists and best practices
around that are even more immature so
we're going to talk about some of the
solutions that we offer on Google cloud
and some of the best practices and
successful techniques that we've seen in
order of in order to run serverless
workloads in production environment my
name is Christopher Sanson I'm a product
manager at Google based out of New York
City I work on CI CD solutions and
developer tooling in general we actually
have an encore session of this talk it
reached full enrollment so if you know
anyone who's interested that wasn't able
to make it in we're gonna have an encore
session of this on Thursday over in the
Metreon next door so I assume many of
you just came from the keynote if you
did you may have seen the presentation
around a new business venture that I
think ORS was was thinking about
starting called the hipster store you
can buy things like old cameras I think
fixie bikes things like that but at
Google you know we're all about sort of
openness open platforms togetherness so
you know the hipster store didn't really
didn't really speak to me as a consumer
so if you're not really interesting that
I'm actually going to start a competing
store it's called the prepster shop so
we're gonna sell things like boat shoes
and Blazers anything with like an anchor
or a lobster on it you know is available
for you there but one big difference
between the hipster shop and the
prepster shop is that mine's entirely
serviced so my front end is running on
firebase hosting my back end is running
on App Engine and I'm using cloud
functions as sort of glue code to wrap
business logic around it and later on
we're going to demo to talk about a
little bit how this is architected and
go through kind of the day in the life
of a developer as I push changes out to
to production but before we can into
that I want to step back just for a
second and sort of set the stage a
little bit and sort of kind of define
serverless is how we define it here
serverless is one of those words it's
kind of like DevOps or CI itself where
you know depending on the context it
means different things to different
people the way that we're gonna use
serverless
is is really applications and services
that you don't really have to think too
much about what they're running on top
of so the idea is that you know you
could just bring your source code and
you don't have to think about versioning
or patching or provisioning or scaling
and all of that is really done for you
the first thing that typically comes to
mind when you hear service is functions
and rightfully so but we definitely see
serverless as a much broader ecosystem
than that we think it includes things
like AI and databases and data
warehousing and on Google Cloud we
actually offer serverless solutions in
each of those different categories when
we talk about del developer solutions in
CI CD we're really mainly focused on
server less compute and we talked about
serverless compute they're really kind
of three primary solutions Google Cloud
functions which is relatively new Google
App Engine which launched ten years ago
this year as one of sort of the pioneers
when it comes to service and firebase
which is kind of part of the extended
family of the
cloud platform so that's sort of how
we're going to talk about serverless
itself so when we talk about CI cd4
server lists you know what do we mean
exactly if you're running CI systems now
you've built your own you might
recognize some of these terms you deal
with things like configuration
management batch jobs maybe ugly things
like nested virtualization if you're
trying to run emulators for Android well
these are definitely other things that
we do not want to worry about anymore
right we want all these problems to go
away I don't want have to think about
having to bake an immutable image to
deploy out to my cloud infrastructure
you know the whole point of service is
to kind of move these infrastructure
pieces below the water line so that your
developers can focus on source code and
not sort of this underlying
infrastructure it would be a real shame
if you know we were able to move to
Cerberus and then our developers had to
like provision of build agent and
configure it to run their builds so what
do we mean for CIC D for service well
it's all the best pieces of CCI CD in
the first place that helps us you know
lower our mean time to release reduce
human error deploy faster and safer and
for us that primarily revolves around
automation so as a developer I want to
you know sit in my chair drink my iced
tea do a get push and then have
everything just sort of magically to
play out to production for me and along
the way we're gonna have to do a couple
steps to our code to get it there we
might not be compiling code but we're
probably gonna be packaging up with
something like web web pack or something
like that
we're definitely gonna want to automate
all of our unit and integration tests
you know we we all have sort of 8090
percent test coverage on our
applications of course so we're gonna
want to make sure we take advantage of
that we're also going to want to have a
manual review process so if you're
familiar with the conversation between
what's continuous delivery and what's
continuous deployment and the difference
being that there's usually a manual
approval step in the real world
almost every change has to be reviewed
by somebody before it goes out right
whether it's sort of a product owner or
management or design team we're gonna
want to make that into our process that
somebody can sort of look at and say you
know okay this looks good this is what
we had in mind we're also going to take
advantage of some of the best practices
around continuous delivery so things
like Bluegreen deployments and canary
you know and this is really to reduce
downtime to our users and also minimize
the blaster
of any errors that do get out like we're
not going to want to deploy something to
100% of users right away we're gonna
canary it out gradually sort of 5% 10%
at a time the last couple as we go
through these we're gonna want to
automate related tasks so things like
creating documentation and stuff that we
often tend to forget and the last is
consistent build environments and this
is just a general best practice around
developer tools I think we all know the
phenomenon of sort of building locally
and then building in the cloud and not
having those to match up and trying to
figure out why so if we look at this
kind of flowchart this probably looks
familiar to most of you this is sort of
a classic software delivery lifecycle
chart as a developer I'm going to do a
get push my source code is then gonna
get packaged and tested and then
deployed to a staging environment from
there we're gonna have a chance to
review and promote that to production
and ultimately deliver it to our users
so when we talk about CI CD you know
it's definitely more of a it's more of a
spectrum it's more of a staircase than
it is like a light switch we did a
recent research asking people you know
do you practice CI CD and one of the
questions is do we ask do you practice
true CI and true CD and only about 15%
of organizations said they did the vast
majority we're self-described as sort of
we do kind of almost CI CD we sort of do
true CD but we sort of almost do CI we
kind of fake it around the edges so what
we find is that most companies who are
trying to move towards full end-to-end
automation are still in that journey and
still getting there so if we look at
kind of the basic and this is in red
because this isn't really even part of
CI CD but it particularly the context of
serverless we still like we're tempted
to do manual deployments you know if I'm
changing a single file or changing an
HTML file what's the big deal I can just
run a deploy script I can go to my
terminal most of these have really
powerful CLI tools I can just manually
deploy but pretty quickly as a developer
I hit a wall with that if I have any
sort of team that's developing together
on a source repo if I want to reduce
errors I'm gonna want to sort of step up
my game and so particularly the content
of CI CD what we see is that a lot of
the services more and more frequently
are coming with baked in smarts so a lot
of the best practices like things like
traffic splitting that we
to self sort of create ourselves and
code our coming is baked in features of
the platform itself I think what we're
gonna see over time is that more and
more of these best practices come
support it out of the box so that every
time you do a deployment you can provide
the test script to run you can tell that
the branch of your repo that you want to
trigger but we're not really there yet
so I think you know as we said
serverless tools are still relatively
new and still evolving space so this is
definitely where we're gonna go but in
terms of building a pipeline we can't
really do it quite yet so the next step
up is you know what I kind of think of
as dev centric CI CD and so in this
world it's very developer focused as a
developer I want to live in my source
code I want to live in my code editor I
want to live at the terminal I want to
make changes and then again I want my
changes to go out to production services
like in this kind of category they're
generally hosted they're generally
pretty easy to use and in this world I
really view my repo as my source of
truth I want to be able to go to might
get repo and get a pretty good sense of
what users are seeing in each stage of
the environment and the final step on
the ladder is kind of ops centric CI
seedy so as we talk to customers
particularly larger ones and enterprises
the dev centric model tends to fall over
at some point so larger customers tend
to be kind of they have very complex and
heterogeneous footprints and they're
always kind of migrating between
multiple services so they may have some
sort of you know legacy platform that's
running on Prem
they're probably deployed in multiple
clouds they may be deploying to
kubernetes and VMs and Windows and Linux
and iOS and operators who are trying to
put out fires all the time really they
just want like a single pane of glass
view across all of these different
deployments and they also want to
enforce compliance as well they want to
have that bottleneck so that they can
have for security and compliance rules
across deployments everywhere and in
that category if you're familiar sort of
worked with Google you may have heard
about spinnaker I know many of you here
actually using it already spinnaker is
an open source multi-cloud continuous
delivery platform
it's co-developed by Google and Netflix
and we have a couple great talks that
really dive deeper into that this week
target is giving one Netflix is actually
here as well they're giving a talk with
Waze about how they use spinnaker
but for the purpose of this talk we're
really going to focus on the dev centric
experience and because we're talking
about serverless the lines between these
categories blur even more sort of we
sort of talked about like we want to
kind of hide the operations piece from
our developers and server this really
lets us do that so we really want to
achieve kind of full automation from the
source repo so I think our first
takeaway is I hope we all sort of
appreciate I imagine we're here in the
room because we generally agree on this
is that you absolutely still need C ICD
solutions built around us and so at
Google this is sort of what what we're
excited to announce so this week and
earlier this morning you heard that we
announced cloud build so Google cloud
build is a hosted CI CD platform running
on Google cloud for automating your
developer workloads and this is actually
an evolution of another Google product
container builder so to give a brief
history if you're familiar with
container builder we launched this a
year ago at GCP next 17 as a way to
build docker images quickly and easily
you could point it at a repo and do a
get push and we would upload your source
code to a VM and the cloud that we
managed do a docker build and push that
out to container registry but from the
very beginning the way we architected
this we sort of had grander visions we
thought you know there's a lot more we
can do with this than just build
containers we can really apply this to
not only containers but sort of other
workflows as well so let's take a look
at kind of how a workflow at cloud build
actually works and we can sort of talk a
little bit how about it applies to
serverless
so we start kind of as we always do with
source code and in the case of
containers we end up with a built in the
container registry and along the way we
upload your source code to the cloud to
Google and we put it in a shared file
system and against that workspace we're
gonna run a series of build steps so
build steps are the naming convention
the cloud build use is it's sort of like
stages or jobs if you're familiar with
that from other CI solutions and in the
context of containers you may do things
like this you may do a docker pull to
fetch a previously built image you may
fetch some dependencies do a docker
build and then push that out to the
registry but sort of the key takeaway or
the key way to look at cloud build and
why it's different is that these build
steps are actually just
Tanner's themselves so everything that
happens in a cloud build is a
containerized task that's completely
isolated and completely defined by you
as the user so because of that people
pretty quickly with container builders
said you know hey wait a minute and ooh
a lot more I can run all sorts of
different things at a container and so
very quickly they started doing things
like building other types of artifacts
so they were doing grave gradle and
maven builds to build tar balls and
binaries pushing that up to cloud
storage they were started running tests
you could run arbitrary bash scripts you
can do curl things like even docker
compose kubernetes users said well I
built the image and I have it on my
worker instead of pushing to a registry
can I just kind of do a git ops model
can I use cube CTL or helm to apply that
out to the cluster and they started
using it that way and I think what we
also saw on the reason we're here is
that it works really great for server
lists applications and that's because I
think one of the coolest parts about
server lists is that almost all the best
services come with really great CLI
tools so things like Sergi cloud and
firebase but even throughout the
ecosystem things like annette LeFay and
Serge and web tasks they all come with
really powerful CL is that really
naturally sort of extend themselves into
containerized workloads and so what you
could do is not only build and test your
code but also deploy it out to
serverless we call these things builder
images and these are the actual
containerized tasks that you can use to
run your different workloads and these
are all open source and you can of
course bring your own I think we have
around 40 or 50 that are contributed by
the community and people have done all
sorts of things we have some for dotnet
there's an Android builder there's
Packer there's Hugo you know you name it
and it just about anything can be run as
a container task so the second takeaway
is that not only do we we really wanted
to still do CI C d-four service but that
you could use cloud build as well for
that solution and in fact that's
actually exactly what we're gonna do so
let's switch back over to our demo and
we're going to look at the prepster
store here and see if we can't sort of
go through a couple real-world examples
of of actually making changes and then
deploying this out so if we could switch
to the demo
great thank you so let's look at our
site here so this is our prepster shop
this is live and up on the web and ready
for business and what we did is we
created two environments so we created
first we created a staging environment
both on firebase which is here and a
production environment and all of our
changes before hitting prod are going to
pass through our staging environment and
if we look at our source repo we'll see
that we are using kind of a sort of a
small mono repo so obviously we could
use micro services but for the sake of
keeping things simple we decided to put
everything in one place so we have a
back-end folder here which is an app
engine app front-end running on firebase
and cloud functions so the site is you
know looking pretty good to me but I got
it in the morning I'm enjoying my first
cup of coffee and the design team comes
running over and they say hey you know
look that the site looks really great we
really like this header bar but we
really need to update it the red color
it's looking a little stale we really
want to turn this to green so I said you
know sure that is no problem so I'm
gonna go back here to my source code go
into the front-end this is an angularjs
app going to source find the CSS file
where that's defined and make my change
so that's here red let's make it green
commit that so I'm gonna commit that in
I'm now going to jump over to the cloud
build UI so this is the cloud build UI
in cloud console this is now a top-level
service so you'll find it directly under
tools and it's no longer nested under
container registry or if you're familiar
with that and if I hit refresh
I'll see that a new build was kicked off
so if I jump into that build we can take
a look at what's happening so this build
was kicked off by my trigger deploy
front-end to staging it's in progress
I'm using some encrypted secrets for my
firebase token for my ultimate
deployment to firebase I'm gonna run a
series of build steps here so first I'm
going to install my node modules using
NPM install and then gonna do a simple
build using NPM run build and then I'm
just going to deploy it out with the
regular
fire base CL I'm doing firebase deploy
to my staging environment and if I look
at the trigger that's set this up I'll
go over here so this is the trigger
it's a cloudbuilt trigger and this is
what the logic that looks for events on
my repo and then kicks off the the
pipeline that I created so for this one
I'm gonna listen to changes on my
staging branch and only changes that
happen in my front end directory so you
saw that we set it up as a mono repo if
I make a change to my back-end I
obviously I don't want to rebuild and
deploy my front end right I only wanted
to play changes that are relevant so
this is a new feature of cloud Bill
that's available as of today we call it
fire file path triggering and it lets
you filter triggers basically on files
that change so we're gonna look for
changes in our friend folder and we're
actually going to ignore some other
files so if I change the readme or a
gate ignore I don't want to trigger a
build on that either so we're going to
ignore any changes to those and then
when that happens we're just use our
cloud build gamal to to configure our
build so if I go back over here to the
build check in on the progress and I
fight the Wi-Fi we'll see that okay the
build is successfully completed and if I
go back to my staging app and refresh
sure enough we see that my change was
successfully deployed so I talked to the
design team I say you know this look
good they say yep looks looks great so
I'm gonna go back to my git repo here it
looks like github was nice enough to
recommend the pull request for me I'm
gonna create this and what I'm gonna do
now to promote it to production is
simply merge it into my master branch so
I'm gonna merge this confirm great so
now this change was on my master and I'm
obviously working from from the UI here
just so I don't have to go through the
full workflow but you know obviously you
from your terminal you can do a git
commit and get pushed to invoke this as
well as your use plugins with your code
editor and if I go back to cloud build
I'll see you another build has been
kicked off which again will do more or
less the same steps but this time we're
deploying to production instead
so if we look at the cloud build a camel
to get a bitter better sense of exactly
how we set this up so let's go to front
end look at the cloud level that
executed we're gonna see more or less
the same build steps that we saw before
so this first one we're installing our
node modules this is the containerized
task that we're running so we're gonna
use NPM and we're gonna pass in our
arguments and just run NPM install and
we're gonna do this in the front end
directory we have a couple other steps
for linting and code testing that we're
just commenting out for the sake of the
demo but we would probably run these as
well we're then going to build with NPM
run build and then simply deploy with
firebase and it comes with built-in
support for kms which is key management
service so that you can encrypt your
tokens to talk to third-party services
so if we go back to the build one other
things that you might have noticed if
you're using container builder they
haven't seen yet is view this build in
the new build result interface so if we
click on that and fight the Wi-Fi
whoo whoa whoa that is not a feature the
demo gods were kind here we go so this
is our new build result UI and you can
see that we're running the same build
that we ran before so we have steps
where we install our new modules run our
builds and deploy and this is currently
in private alpha but this is gonna be
rolling out later this year and what we
heard from users over and over was that
the UI is really great but as a
developer I really want to be able to
debug my builds quickly and also have
more kind of a dashboard view of what
the status of my different deployed
applications are so we're building a new
UI from scratch to help sort of enable
that so if I look here it says that
looks like this build was successful and
if I go back to production here and
refresh sure enough my change is out and
I'm done so I send a slack message to
the design team it says good news our
changes are live so I'm feeling good I'm
going back to my coffee and before I can
relax too much
I see the sales team runs over the sales
team runs over and says hey Christopher
good news bad news the good news is the
linen blazer has been extremely popular
the bad news is that were sold out so we
don't have any left and can we update
the database to sort of indicate that -
so that we don't get any more orders
before we get more in so we say you know
sure no problem
so for that we're gonna jump into our
back-end so if we go back to our repo
here this is just a regular App Engine
app we've created two versions of it one
for staging which we're going to deploy
to our staging service and one to
production which we're just gonna use
our default and if we jump into our App
j/s and find out where our API response
is coming from this is our fancy
inventory management service here turn
this to true commit that to staging
there we go and if we go back to the
cloud build again and refresh you'll see
that a new build has been kicked off
this one is triggered on deploy back
into staging so again we're looking only
for changes to our back-end folder and
this one's pretty simple we're just
running basically a g-cloud app to
Floy to our staging service one thing
that's interesting that you'll notice
here is that we're actually going to
pass in a version ID so if you're
familiar with App Engine if you don't
specify one app engine we'll provide you
with a unique ID but it doesn't really
tell you much about what was actually
deployed so we're actually going to pass
in the commit sha as our ID to all of
our App Engine deployments and this way
if we go to our App Engine interface and
want to sort of understand what's in
production or what's on staging we can
really quickly and easily map it back to
the committee shop so we know exactly
what source code was in there so if we
let that change go out
it looks like the build is completing
and it's done I will go over here
refresh and let's see App Engine can be
fairly efficient with its caching some
time so if I go to the API response and
give that a chance to refresh here and
okay so sold-out is true so we should
see that as well in our front-end now
and we do so our linen blazer here is
transferred to sold out and I can no
longer buy it looks good to me it's a
pretty straightforward change so let's
do the same trick we did before let's go
back to our code repo let's merge this
into master and push that out and so for
our our push to production we're
actually gonna do a little something
different so we talked earlier around
how we want to Canary changes out to
users and not necessarily deploy them to
a hundred percent of people all at once
and if we go in here to our build and we
look at the build steps that ran we're
doing kind of we're doing some more
things here so let's look at our club
builder mo and sort of investigate a
little further out what's going on so
we're gonna go to our club o mo for
production and what we're going to do is
actually so the way App Engine works is
that when you do a deployment and you
give it your source code it actually
builds a container under the hood using
cloud build itself and then deploys that
container out so when we're deploying a
production we're actually going to do
this process ourself manually
instead of deploying source code we're
gonna build the container ahead of time
and then pass that in so this way I
actually now have an artifact of what
was released at any time so if anything
ever goes wrong in production I could
pull that container down and run it
locally I can also use it for things
like integration tests and smoke tests
and things like that so we're going to
NPM test we're gonna do docker build and
then we're going to use the image URL
flag to to play that out to App Engine
the other thing that we're gonna do is
we're actually going to canary this
change out so we're gonna use the no
promote flag to deploy the version but
not actually send any traffic over yet
and what we're gonna do here is we're
gonna actually do a little bash a little
blow scripting here so everything we've
done so far has been pretty
straightforward like firebase deploy
g-cloud app deploy for canary now we're
gonna jump into bash so this is a
container I can just set my entry point
to anything I want and we're gonna grab
the version that users are currently
seen so we're gonna do G cloud app
versions list sort it by the amount of
traffic that it's getting and just grab
the first one we're then going to have a
really very pretty Python script to grab
that version ID and then use the G cloud
set traffic field to programmatically
canary this change out and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take the version
that we just deployed which we tagged to
the commit sha and give that five
percent we're then going to take the
version that's currently getting traffic
and give that ninety five percent and so
if we go over to App Engine here and hit
refresh sure enough we'll see that the
build that we just did is currently
being rolled out to five percent of our
users and what's great is that app
engine comes baked in with things like
traffic splitting so we can go in here
and then assuming things look good roll
this out as we see fit so we're going to
roll it out to a hundred percent so that
was safe successfully and if we go back
we'll see that we have successfully sort
of canary this change out so let's take
a change oh let's just confirm here that
that actually works yep and sure enough
it's in production in live oh all right
so if we take a little breath and just
look at everything we just accomplished
with just a couple changes to our get
repo we're able to stage and deploy
changes to
our front end and our back end and if
you notice like we were jumping around
in the UI to sort of show you what was
going on behind the scenes but really
isn't as a developer I never really had
to leave my leave my code editor I could
just do all this from the terminal I
could do this all this from github or
the source repository that you're using
and just push those changes out and not
have to worry about anything so we're
feeling pretty good I was gonna take a
break but I see the CEO is running over
the CEO comes over and we had previously
set up an alert so every time we made a
large sale as a startup we were very
excited we set it up so that she gets a
text message so that she got this Gong
in the office and she likes like every
time we have a big sale she likes to go
and ring the gong and sort of celebrate
turns out she got a new phone number
over the weekend and really needs us to
update where we're sending those text
messages to so for that we're gonna jump
back into our code and go into cloud
functions so cloud functions is
definitely one of the things that we
hear from customers the most about sort
of how do i how do I run functions or
manage functions at scale like when I
have one function or two functions it's
pretty straightforward but if I start
getting fifty or a hundred how can I
automate this in a safe way I don't want
to have to manually update my index.js
file every time I create a new one and I
don't want to deploy all my functions
every single time I make a change so
we're gonna do a couple things via
convention and a couple things by a
technology here to make sure that this
works so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to put our functions
in this functions folder here and so
these are our functions on large sales
the one we care about but we have a
whole bunch so we have off login logout
user on create on delete and if you
notice that we added an extension here
to each one of these fjs and this is
going to let us do some kind of fancy
stuff so if we go to our index dot JSP
we do a couple tricks here some you may
be familiar with some may be new so the
way functions works is that it looks for
exported functions in your index.js file
and what we're going to do is actually
glob over that functions folder grab
every file that ends in F KS and then
we're going to loop over it and convert
that file path to a function name so in
the case of auth
we're gonna convert that to a camel's
case to function name called auth on
create and then we're actually going to
we're actually going to create two
versions of every function so for every
function that we have we're going to
create one sort of regular version often
create and one for staging so we're
going to append an underscore stage into
every single function as well and make
both of these available to ourselves so
we go back to our code here and let's go
ahead and make that change and sort of
see what happens so I go in here and
we're using Twilio to send an SMS
message and I'm going to update the
phone number and commit that out and if
I go over to club build hit refresh
there's our new build we're going to
jump in so what we're going to do is
we're going to this function called
deploy updated functions so let's look
at the cloud build and sort of see
what's happening here so you see again
we're doing the same steps we're going
to use yarn this time to do yarn install
we have some unit tests that we've
commented out so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to create a
cached version of all the functions that
we deploy and put it up in cloud storage
and then every time we do a deployment
we're going to recursively loop over
that functions folder look for changes
and deploy only those files that changed
so we can walk through that a little bit
so the first step is we're gonna grab
our functions dot staging folder from
the cloud and look at what functions are
currently live in staging we're then
going to do a diff and loop over
comparing our local fun clinch function
changes to the changes that are out in
staging we're going to use this dot n
flag to look for new files as well that
we've introduced and then for each
function each file that's different
we're going to convert that file path to
a name again using our camelcase
convention and then just deploy that
function out this time to staging and
we're going to pass in our environment
variables using KMS again for Twilio so
if we look at our build see how that's
coming along and we can go down here we
can look at log
we can reverse these so looks like it's
deployed looks like it just finished and
if we go to cloud functions so this is
what it looks like when I've deployed
all my functions so for every function
that we had on login off logout we have
two versions staging in prod and if we
hit refresh we'll notice that of the
ones that he's deployed only this one on
large sale staging was updated recently
so we didn't have to deploy any of the
other functions and as you get to scale
with hundreds of functions this becomes
really nice so we just employed the only
one that changed and if we'd like to how
that went we can go back and again do
the same thing merge that into master
and then deploy that out as well so now
this is just going to go ahead and roll
out to production and our CEO will
successfully get all text message dates
and be able to sort of celebrate our
wins with our team right so that's more
or less our demo as a developer I was
able to pretty quickly and easily in
about 10 or 20 minutes push changes out
to firebase App Engine and cloud
functions with kind of little to no
effort outside of just doing a simple
get to push deploy so if we go back to
the presentation this was all done with
cloud build and so with cloud build just
real quickly we're going to go through
some of the new features that are
available today that we used in the demo
its top level in the cloud console so
you'll see it there we're adding support
for first-class artifacts so the same
way that you could push images to
container registry you can now push
artifacts to cloud storage so if we're
building things that like binaries or
just regular folders we added support
for file path triggers which we used
pretty extensively in order to filter
based on subdirectory and that we have
two new changes that are currently in
private alpha a bigger are going to be
coming soon this one is probably the one
I'm most excited about and the one that
we hear from customers the most is a
deeper integration with github itself so
we're adding native built-in support for
pull requests posting status back to the
new checks API
as well as the ability to
programmatically create triggers via the
API so instead of having to go to the UI
if you're creating lots and lots of
triggers you can do it now via the API
and that's all going to be rolling out
soon is available in alpha and then last
is the new result UI that we showed so Y
Club billed for server lists its server
list to kind of you know we didn't
really have to provision anything we
didn't really have to think about what
it was running on we just submitted a
cloud build a ml file
it's pay-as-you-go it's a pretty good
free tier it's 123 minutes a day the
builds particularly for serverless you
know we're one or two minutes long so
this is a pretty good deal it's highly
configurable you could bring your own
container you can run your own tasks and
it's developer friendly so everything we
showed was running in the cloud but it
actually comes with a local binary cloud
build local so you can run builds on
your workstation and you can trigger
builds from API or SDK so if we go back
to our flow diagram here I think we sort
of we showed doing a git push through
staging and we were able to use cloud
build in order to improve your developer
velocity and increase faster and safer
deployments to serverless runtimes like
App Engine cloud functions and firebase
thank you very much
[Music]